depuis déjà plusieurs semaines nous nous
faisons l'écho des grandes mobilisations
tourangelles ou les Oise qui
s'organisent contre la réforme des
retraites aujourd'hui nous vous emmenons
à Preuilly sur claises un village de
1000 habitants dans le sud de
l'Indre-et-Loire là-bas aussi la colère
gronde contre la retraite à 64 ans mais
évidemment de manière moins visible
quand les campagnes se mobilisent pour
le maintien d'une retraite à 62 ans
c'est un reportage de Florent Clavel
les drapeaux CGT les slogans et même la
caisse de grève au plus fort de la
mobilisation d'acompté jusqu'à quatre
gendarmes pour encadrer les manifestants
au nombre de 50
rencontré beaucoup de personnes qui ne
pouvaient pas se rendre à Tours ou à
Châtellerault globalement justement on a
constaté que les personnes étaient très
mécontentes et puis il suffit d'être
trois ou quatre même pour simplement
organiser une manifestation ça demande
pas beaucoup de moyens et c'est à la
portée tout le monde ici
Preuilly-sur-Claise petite commune de
1000 habitants et faire de lance de la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites en Sud Touraine un premier
rassemblement avait réuni une centaine
de personnes Quentin 30 ans a saisi
cette nouvelle opportunité pour
manifester son opposition je travaille à
zelferon et là du coup j'ai pris une
petite pause pour pour revenir pour la
manif il y a plein de façons d'être
compte d'être réforme et d'exprimer que
ce soit sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit dans le lieu de travail avec la
famille les amis mais ça en fait partie
pour être visible quoi organiser par des
membres de la majorité mais aussi de
l'opposition municipale cette action se
veut transpartisane l'occasion en milieu
rural de faire sortir les habitants pour
se retrouver autour de valeurs communes
en effet de d'être solidaire de montrer
aussi de soutenir aussi de se dire qu'on
n'est pas tout seul dans notre coin à
penser ça et pouvoir peut-être échanger
sur les luttes à poursuivre et sur ce
qui se passe en règle générale parce
qu'ici on parle aussi beaucoup climat on
est contre la réforme des retraites mais
on parle aussi beaucoup climat climat et
retraite donc mais aussi transport santé
et éducation proie au carrefour de
multiples revendications
n'a pas fini de se faire entendre